okay it's our last day on the boat the
boat stopped moving we're getting up
soon happy day
it's 5 a.m i've never been so excited at
5am we're gonna get breakfast
hopefully it's open at five in the
morning then uh then get off yes and
head our way towards beijing
okay we made it to the tianjin station
and it's a chaos zoo but nina saved us
being able to translate everything and
we're stopping for some
lunch kind of
what are we eating here what's this this
is the meat bun meatballs and this is
the beef brisket
how is train station food babe
here we go
not that good okay good
better
we are here in the beijing train station
and of course we need to go to
the starbucks
because i am crashing so that train took
like half an hour to get here hit almost
300 kilometers an hour
and i'm gonna get some coffee then find
the cab and make our way to our beijing
airbnb location once again the starbucks
in china doesn't let us get free wi-fi
without a phone number from china
boo starbucks how do we feel about that
nina
not happy
okay we've arrived at our beijing uh
apartment
it's a pretty cool place yeah just left
what was the guy's name uh jason jason
super friendly got a lot of stuff
organized for us nina's gonna take us on
the tour
hello
this is the bedroom
hey
get up
this is the makeup table
if you carry the um
the makeup remover sponge
see we don't even know what that is
and then he also
has the the q-tips oh cool okay yeah
and this is the washroom the washroom
the washroom is separated from the from
the bathroom
it's the japanese one
where it has all these different options
on it
i'm going to do the wash i want to feel
what that's like really you're going to
do it why not okay when you're in
beijing you got to act like a chinese
person no when this is japanese stuff
okay just
it's a small kitchen whatever it works
but it's it's it's look at the wrench
yeah is that a fan yeah it's a fan
that's messed up it's very clean
actually
he gave us some green tea okay you want
some tea and the filter uh
right we can't we can't drink water you
cannot drink the tap water
and then toaster if you want to make
some bread
and he got us some snacks all right
juice and egg rolls yeah he said he
loved it yeah he loved egg rolls i like
this dog look at this dog pillow
bathroom bathroom the tub is is a wooden
tub with a shower oh and a rain shower
did you see that there's two shower
heads
nice i might sit in there no but do you
know how many people been using this
oh and show the ceiling so here you can
hang you can hang your your wet clothes
he's got this little device that lowers
it
so you can hang your clothes easily i
thought that's pretty cool okay that's
the two of our place we are trying to
figure out the wi-fi situation and how
to access google because i don't have
any access to my emails um i need to let
people know hey when i'm coming home to
get my ride
and then we're gonna go explore beijing
we'll see you soon we're gonna head out
soon but before i have to go to the
washroom and i'm gonna check out the new
japanese wash your butt feature
i just got out how is it
i kind of feel violated
welcome to the streets of beijing we're
heading towards the
forbidden city i think we got our map
our first purchase
nina got into a huge fight
but she was yelling at me yeah first she
said it was three yen just three yuan
and then look how beat up it is at the
top it's already been used then she said
it was five you won
for the english version
anyway we got our map we know where
we're going
wow
very cool holy cow this place is huge
that was the outer court where they
would hold all of the events public
ceremonies now we're going into the
inner court
where the emperor
and his family live
this place is huge it's just building
after building after building after
building
all the way around
this is the exit of the forbidden palace
that was a lot of fun i almost passed
out on the street a couple times i
haven't eaten
in i don't know how long hours and hours
so we were on the hunt for food couldn't
find anything so we just stopped at our
mcdonald's
just to get a little bit of a sit-down
break and
something in our bodies even if it's not
the most healthy
but uh yeah that was scary i i almost
passed that on the street had to stop
was feeling dizzy
so i don't know i don't know what's
going on we're gonna have dinner
and uh and then keep going out and
exploring
we're on the wang fujing shopping area
it's all pedestrian
surrounded by huge
shops everywhere and i'm still feeling
uh pretty woozy running a fever so we're
gonna we're gonna head home call it an
early night
plan out the map and then start again
fresh tomorrow
okay we're here in beijing we had a
great sleep i am no longer do you have a
great you had a great sleep i didn't
sleep well nina didn't sleep well i had
a great sleep i'm feeling really excited
today
i no longer have sea legs i'm not
fainting i'm not hallucinating anymore
this is amazing we're gonna go explore
some more beijing today
uh hopefully be able to spend a full day
out wandering around we asked our host
where the best place to get breakfast
was you know some authentic beijing
breakfast and what did he say
kfc
he said kfc it's not the usual kfc that
you have in north america they have
kanji and a bunch of stuff so
i guess we're going to look for kfc for
breakfast and then
explore beijing
we were supposed to go in to see
chairman mao's body
but uh they wouldn't let us bring any
bags in they wouldn't let me bring my
camera bag and they wouldn't let nemo
bring no i could bring my bag but just i
can't bring the camera in oh they won't
let us bring our cameras and we're
supposed to check them
back there if you can see that the area
covered intense anyway i don't feel safe
leaving my uh 2 000 camera
with them so we're not going to go to
the chairman now we're going to continue
on our tour
look for a starbucks
what do you think
yeah okay look for starbucks and uh see
what happens next
so we found our noodle place
and i had to pull up the camera because
nina's looking extra pretty
so it's cool here they give you a
package of a chopstick and a napkin
she's got a beer coming
what kind of beer is this
yanjing beer what is this
oh this is the mix your own noodles
cool
this we ate at was super fresh noodles
and you can see why they make it
fresh here
uh on the spot
before it comes to your uh your plate
it's cool
all right next up after a long walk
we're entering
the one of the largest parks in beijing
to see the temple of the heaven
okay we're leaving the temple and are on
our way to the echo wall where i assume
we're going to hear our echoes i think
it's kind of uh
people trying to kind of rip off on the
marketing
this this whole thing is surrounded by a
little wall
and it doesn't really make a huge echo
there's some people who are clapping but
you don't really hear a massive echo as
it goes around
it's it's you're little you could kind
of hear it but not it's some rip-off
marketing people
coming at the echo wall and there's very
little echo
anyway it looks it looks pretty enough
we're going to continue on
now we're heading towards the last part
the circular mound
one thing that's crazy in beijing is the
pollution look at the sun
it's not behind clouds it's hard to see
because there's so much pollution here
that you can't see anything
we are here at the pearl market which is
a huge uh shopping area i don't know if
you guys can see it feels like there's a
a haze over the whole city you look
again look at that sun
it's just hazy there's so much pollution
here
it may be the most polluted city i've
ever been in my throat is starting to
itch how's your throat is your throat
okay babe a little bit hurting yeah
let me because you're yelling at me too
much
but my throat hurts because
it's a lot of pollution
we didn't end up buying anything at the
pearl market but the sales people are
super aggressive and pushy and like
throwing stuff in your face and rubbing
stuff on your skin
um and i had to shush a couple of them
so that was fun
so we didn't buy anything but uh
we're getting hungry and we are gonna go
find
some peking duck because when you come
to beijing you have to get peking duck
it's a
national treasure
so we're going to go to one of the
famous pekin duck places hopefully they
have space and we're going to enjoy some
food
try the skin with the sugar okay
oh just on its own yeah
okay
and nothing
so all of that worked out to only about
50 bucks 50 bucks under 50 bucks
but they wouldn't take my visa card for
some reason so
nina paid for it
thanks nina what a great dinner
we just picked up a chinese hat oh there
you go for hayden and it has a little
thing tail at the back
and it walked into the store and oh
that's too big for too small for me oh
whatever we walked into the store
and said uh
how much does it cost she said 30 yuan
which is
oh 21 is that it yes 21 which is like
three bucks
and then we just walked on by and she
came back and said 15.
and we hung around there for a little
bit and nina asked me so what do you
want to do you want to take up the 15
you won i said you know what let's let's
just walk out and see what happens and
so we walked out and she said ten ten
you want i know she didn't say she asked
me how much would you want to pay oh and
then i say 10 yards
oh you negotiated that
oh i and i totally messed up that story
okay good so we got it for 10 yuan
instead of 20. which so it's like a
dollar a dollar 50 or something yeah
anyway look at that hat i think he's
gonna go crazy where's the tail
oh i think he's gonna i think he's gonna
love it anyway i really wanted to try a
grasshopper or a scorpion or something
but after seeing the move on the stick i
got grossed out
and then nina reminded me that a lot of
these people
they probably use the sewage oil
something like that
they they we saw this happening in uh
where is in shanghai yeah where they
open up sewers this woman this woman is
sitting there opening up a steward
taking buckets of oil off the top of the
sewer the sewer water and they use that
to cook
for the street food
oh
that is some nasty stuff and so that
combined with the thought of eating it
eating that thing that was moving it's
like okay i don't know i'm getting
ghosted i can't eat this anyway there's
a lot of gross here in china combined
with the smog let me let me show you the
smog
look at the fog can you see that
pollution anywhere you go there's
crazy pollution
anyway it comes into your throat
makes you want to cough
there's a lot of grossness here but
there's also some fun
every week i share my best information
to help you fuel your business forward
in my newsletter check it out below
hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of
riseonline.com and i want to say evan
carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period